tf1 20 heures avec jean claude bourret
économies d'énergie certains états
américains décident de rationner
l'essence grande-bretagne madame
thatcher désigne le gouvernement
conservateur un absent de marque
l'ancien premier ministre edward heath
l'europe
à cinq semaines du 10 juin la première
page spéciale ce soir du journal des
élections rugby demain c'est la suite
des quarts de finale du championnat les
chances de griller un reportage de
pierre torre mal à mademoiselle monsieur
bonsoir
l'ambassadeur de france à san salvador
et l'attaché commercial sont toujours
entre les mains d'une quinzaine de
commandos du bloc populaire
révolutionnaire cette organisation
réclame la libération de cinq
prisonniers politiques en échange de la
vie de l'ambassadeur de france
jacques grignan du moulin vient de
réussir à joindre par téléphone l'un des
commandos révolutionnaire vous allez
constater que la conversation a été
courte et brutale
voilà les conversations reprendront il y
aura dieu communiqué de ses commandos
dès qu'il y aura une progression de ces
négociations le gouvernement français a
pris contact avec le gouvernement du
salvador pour exprimer sa préoccupation
le ministère français des affaires
étrangères suit en permanence le
déroulement de la situation le
gouvernement du salvador liberati les
cinq prisonniers politiques comme
l'exigent le commando révolutionnaire
les négociations continuent à ce propos
et j'apprends à l'instant qu'un
émissaire du quai d'orsay a été dépêchée
au salvador
tandis qu' il y a sur place un
durcissement de la position des
commandes alerte à la pénurie d'essence
aux états unis un plan de rationnement
aurait été mise au point pour les
prochaines grandes vacances ces
informations alarmistes abondamment
reprise par les journaux américains ont
provoqué l'inquiétude des conducteurs
ainsi en californie l'un des états les
plus motorisée
et pompiste vendent maintenant en 90
minutes leur production quotidienne
habituelle des files de voitures se
forment devant les pompes qui ont été
obligés d'afficher des heures
d'ouverture pour la distribution du
carburant
la menace sur l'essence aux états unis
un reportage de notre envoyé spécial
dominique bromberger un mois de 5 week
end il n'en aura pas fallu plus pour que
pendant les trois derniers jours d'avril
bon nombre d'automobilistes américains
risquent de se retrouver sans essence
samedi 28 et dimanche 29 avril cette
station service sur dix étaient fermés
en maryland et en virginie
huit sur dix dans le nord-est du pays 9
sur 10 dans les faubourgs de los angeles
et celles qui restaient ouvertes voyait
des files d'automobiles s'allonger
derrière leurs pompes
en californie une dispute entre
automobilistes impatients faisait un
mort au nevada des touristes se
retrouver immobilisés dans le désert
avec le début du mois de mai les
livraisons ont repris mais selon les
marques d'essence ces livraisons ne
représente que de 70 à 90 % de ce
qu'elle était l'année dernière à la même
époque
vers la fin du mois les mêmes scènes de
pénurie risque donc de se reproduire
d'autant que la consommation elle
entre-temps a progressé de 4% aussi en
californie le gouverneur brown at il
décidé que les voitures à numéros
impairs ne serait servi que les jours
impairs et les voitures à numéros pairs
les jours pairs quant au prix il atteint
en moyenne 1 franc le litre ce qui bien
que très faible pour un européen
représente une hausse d'environ 20% sur
l'année dernière et semble considérable
à l'américain qui continuent de conduire
une voiture extraordinairement gourmande
explication officielle du phénomène les
problèmes d'approvisionnement surtout
depuis la révolution iranienne
mais l'opinion publique est sceptique
pour elle ce sont les compagnies qui
organise la pénurie selon un sondage
récent 54% des américains refusent
encore de considérer que la crise de
l'énergie est un problème réel et le
président carter rencontres les plus
grandes difficultés au congrès à se
faire accorder les pouvoirs nécessaires
pour la mise en place en cas de besoin
d'un plan de rationnement inutile de 10
que les vacances risque d'être difficile
sur les routes américaines
en france pas de menace mais une hausse
continuelle des prix des carburants la
dernière en date a eu lieu ce matin à
zéro heure + 11 centimes sur l'essence
et le super + 6 centimes sur le gazole +
5 centimes sur le fuel
quant à l'électricité ses tarifs
augmenteront de 7 et demi pour cent
après demain l'essence française est
devenue maintenant très cher c'est la
plus chère de l'europe des neuf
ce n'est pas la plus chère du monde fort
heureusement la hausse continuelle des
pays producteurs de pétrole n'explique
pas tout les explications de michel
chevalet d'abord le détail de ce prix du
litre d'essence
oui on va prendre si vous voulez une
bouteille symbolique représentant un
litre d'essence alors examinons en
détail vient tout d'abord en bas 71
centime c'est le prix du litre de super
à la sortie de la raffinerie il faut
ajouter 27 centimes pour des frais
divers des redevances il faut penser aux
transports la distribution
ensuite vous voyez the 2 centimes
seulement pour les bénéfices de la
compagnie pétrolière ainsi que du
pompiste et on arrive regardez c'est un
compte rond ce n'est pas un hasard
un franc voilà ce que devrait nous
coûter théoriquement notre litre de
super sans malheureusement les taxes
alors la regarder un franc 44 d'abord de
taxes ensuite il faut ajouter et bien
oui la fameuse tva 17 6 % 42 centimes à
nouveau et on arrive bien sûr à deux
francs 86 alors maintenant est
intéressant et viens de regarder le
palmarès du litre de super dans le monde
alors nous avons pris seulement quelques
exemples alors si nous payons le plus de
taxes dans le monde sur l'essence par
contre nous ne sommes pas les plus
chères regarder le premier vient c'est
le portugal il franchit la barre des 3
francs 3 francs ici et 10 centimes et
bientôt m'a-t-on dit 3 francs et 60
centimes dans les semaines qui viennent
numéro 2 la france nous frisons la barre
des trois fronts et semble-t-il à fin de
l'année nous la franchiront l'italie 2
francs 50 saisir 500 lire la belgique
2.40 l'allemagne environ 2,2 et les usa
vous voyez 80 centimes actuelle
avec le rationnement et bien c'est ce
que nous a dit david bon berger par loin
d'un franc alors il ya un mot qui
revient toujours c'est le mot
rationnement et là je crois qu'il faut
envisager et bien trois scénarios
possibles le premier rationnement et
bien c'est le rationnement spéculatifs
c'est-à-dire que les compagnies
pétrolières ferme d'elle-même le robinet
du pétrole et par de la laisse monter
les prix le deuxième rationnement et
bien ce serait le rationnement
autoritaire du gouvernement c'est à dire
sans dire les bons les coupons d'essence
et le troisième rationnement et bien je
crois que c'est celui qui aura cours en
france et bien c'est malheureusement le
rationnement par le prix merci pour ces
explications michel chevalet
les spécialistes ne pourront pas
pénétrer avant un an dans la centrale
nucléaire de three mile island la
décontamination de l'ensemble du
bâtiment prendra au moins deux ans les
spécialistes estiment que 30 % des
éléments combustibles du coeur du
réacteur ont été gravement endommagés le
détecteur de radioactivité du grand cerf
dans la drôme a accusé ce matin pendant
une vingtaine de minutes
une radioactivité anormale de 8000 irem
déjà vendredi dernier deux détecteurs de
radioactivité de la drôme s'était
déclenché à plusieurs reprises sous
l'effet d'une radioactivité d'un me lire
m
les spécialistes avaient estimé que
cette radioactivité avait été provoqué
par un orage
pour l'instant aucune explication n'a
été donnée à cette radioactivité 8 fois
supérieure à celle de la semaine
dernière
les spécialistes vont se rendre une
nouvelle fois sur place
la préfecture de la drôme de la drôme
précise qu'aucun danger n'est à craindre
compte tenu du niveau très faible de
radioactivité et dans un communiqué que
j'ai reçu il ya quelques minutes la
préfecture de la drôme précise que cette
dose d'aujourd'hui à titre de
comparaison est extrêmement faible
puisqu'une simple radiographie médicale
représente une dose absorbée de 9 à 8 à
300 me lire m
alors que là il s'agit d'après la
préfecture n'ont pas de 8 mai de 3000
rennes
le conseil d'état a rejeté hier les 89
requête en annulation de la déclaration
d'utilité publique de la centrale
nucléaire de creys malville en isère
haroun tazieff alain bombard et le
commandant cousteau avait déposé avec
plusieurs associations et trois conseils
généraux des recours en annulation
les acquéreurs d'un chauffe eau solaire
ou d'un chauffage
l'air peuvent bénéficier d'une prime de
1000 francs cent mille centime s'ils
font procéder à cette installation avant
le 30 juin prochain
la demande de prime doit être adressée
au directeur départemental de
l'équipement
cette information a été publiée ce matin
par le journal officiel le nouveau
gouvernement britannique a été formé
après le succès des conservateurs aux
élections c'est lord carrington qui a
été nommé secrétaire au foreign office
c'est à dire ministre des affaires
étrangères avec andré célarié le détail
de ce nouveau gouvernement britannique
willard carrington voici leur carry
tonnes 60 ans est un homme d'affaires il
a fait une brillante carrière militaire
et puis une brillante carrière politique
dans les différents gouvernements
conservateurs depuis la guerre mam
satcher a été vite aujourd'hui pour
former son équipe et l'a présenté vous
allez voir chacun des principaux
ministres arrivant à downing street
chacun dans son style mindset cher la
voici qui arrive à downing street
aujourd'hui voici le nouveau chancelier
de l'échiquier le ministre des finances
hurd geoffroy roux l'homme qui devra
réduire la charge fiscale des ménages
william whitelaw première adjointe
madame thatcher qui prend le poste de
ministre de l'intérieur un habile
écossais de 62 ans soeur qui joseph
ministre de l'industrie il passe pour un
conservateur partisan de la libre
entreprise sans frein on le dit très
écoutée d'un match air france estime à
la défense l'homme qui monte chez les
conservateurs un successeur possible de
madame thatcher à l'habile négociateurs
à l'âme à suivre malang faty ramener les
choses rondement la télévision
soviétique affirmé ce matin que les
milieux d'affaires britanniques
attendent du gouvernement conservateur
une attaque contre les droits des
travailleurs
parallèlement la chine populaire s'est
félicité de l'élection de margaret
thatcher et de la victoire des
conservateurs
monsieur raymond barre le premier
ministre français a adressé au nom de
son gouvernement ses félicitations
madame thatcher première femme appelée à
diriger le gouvernement d'une grande
puissance européenne
5 millions d'électeurs autrichiens vont
désigner demain les 183 membres du
nouveau parlement le parti socialiste du
chansonnier renault price qui mènent une
lutte difficile pour sauver sa faible
majorité
le chancelier autrichien a déclaré
aujourd'hui qu'il accepterait de rester
au pouvoir sur la base d'un accord
politique avec l'opposition
au cas où son parti perdrait la majorité
une enquête de notre envoyé spécial
michelle wie
en autriche c'est lors des élections
législatives du 6 mai que va se jouer le
sort du gouvernement du chancelier bruno
kreisky au pouvoir depuis dix ans le
parti socialiste autrichiens comptent
sur la personnalité de son leader juan o
kreis qui pour battre une nouvelle fois
ses adversaires chrétien démocrate
la campagne électorale est très
personnalisés les autrichiens le 6 mai
ne voteront pas pour un programme il
voterait pour ou contre le chancelier
pour le candidat du parti populaire
autrichien le chrétien démocrate joseph
south l'actuel chef de gouvernement mène
l'autriche à la ruine
les socialistes ont considérablement
endetté notre pays
nous voulons une nouvelle politique
économique pour permettre une reprise
des investissements
c'est le programme du parti populaire
autrichien bruno kreisky sûr de son
immense popularité refuse de faire des
concessions
il veut continuer à gouverner seul il
n'y aura pas de gouvernement de
coalition
selon lui le bilan économique du parti
socialiste autrichien est positif
6h sur économique et entre 1 quand on
compare avec les autres et cela l'a
trouvé le moyen des grands problèmes et
c'est vrai que nous avons des problèmes
budgétaires mais je suis tout à fait
convaincu qu elle est gogo devance
social démocrate est capable de résoudre
la plupart des autrichiens considère
monsieur crise qui comme l'homme
politique du siècle
son seul échec le référendum sur le
nucléaire à la suite duquel le
gouvernement autrichien a dû renoncer à
la construction de l'unique centrale
nucléaire
le chancelier a su changer son fusil
d'épaulé
l'écologie est maintenant le thème
principal de ses discours
je ne suis pas socialiste mais je dois
dire que bruno price qui a été et reste
un grand tonnes en fait on ne voit pas
très bien pour le moment qui pourrait
remplacer monsieur kreis qui le
chancelier a permis à son pays de jouer
un rôle important dans les relations
internationales
l'autriche est devenue un trait d'union
entre l'est et l'ouest
pour nous c'est une vraie une
modification d'un mot de grandes herriot
il a dit qu'on stabilise la démocratie
quand on prends ton franc la démocratie
est en mouvement
je vais dire on stabilise par des tentes
quand on fait tous pour pour le
développer le 6 mai les autrichiens
devront décider si oui ou non
l'autriche a besoin de price qui comme
le proclament les affiches du parti
socialiste
jean paul ii a complété aujourd'hui son
équipe de direction il a nommé un
espagnol secrétaire général du vatican
il s'agit de monseigneur somalo le
saint-père a nommé également le cardinal
bertoli au poste de camerlingue c'est un
poste de premier plan puisque le
camerlingue et le cardinal qui dirige
l'église à la mort d'un pape et qui
remplace le souverain pontife 40 il
s'absente du vatican le cardinal bertone
y connais très bien la france puisqu'il
est resté neuf ans nonce apostolique à
paris alerte policière général sur tout
le territoire de la république fédérale
allemande à la suite de la mort hier
soir à nuremberg d'elisabeth van dyck
les enquêteurs ont en effet découvert
dans l'appartement où ils ont abattu
elizabeth van dyck les traces du passage
de cinq autres extrémistes
trois d'entre eux sont soupçonnés
d'avoir participé à l'enlèvement et à
l'assassinât du président du patronat
allemand monsieur schleyer et de ses
quatre gardes du corps
elizabeth van dyck a battu hier soir
alors qu'elle s'apprêtait à tirer sur
les policiers étaient également
soupçonné d'avoir participé à
l'assassinât de monsieur gelé hier
pendant 75 minutes hier à villeneuve sur
lot dans le lot et garonne le président
valéry giscard d'estaing a été l'invité
du forum de la presse de radio monte
carlo et de la grande presse régionale
de nombreux sujets ont évidemment été
abordée avec patrice duhamel l'essentiel
de l'intervention du président de la
république
fidèle à l'esprit et à la lettre les
institutions je les laisserais comme je
les ai trouvés lorsque je quitterai
l'exercice de la fonction présidentielle
je ne demande à personne d'être
giscardien mais je demande que mes
compatriotes veuille bien soutenir la
fonction et l'action du président de la
république que la majorité de ses
concitoyens à porter à la responsabilité
suprême le débat politique français a un
caractère de personnalisation excessif
il devrait porter davantage sur les
choix et sur les idées
ces quelques phrases ces quelques
citations situe bien le niveau très
présidentiel au dessus du tohu-bohu
politique où se situe le chef de l'état
et où il s'est situé tout au long de
cette émission sur l'europe le président
giscard d'estaing a donc réaffirmé il
était dans le sud-ouest l'objectif
d'élargissement de la communauté vers le
sud
un élargissement qui fera de la france
le centre de gravité de cette nouvelle
europe et qui bénéficiera ainsi au sud
ouest en même temps il a insisté sur la
fermeté avec laquelle les négociations
pour l'adhésion de l'espagne seront
menées des négociations difficiles et
longues qui rentrent au delà de la durée
de réalisation du programme décennal
pour le sud-ouest des négociations qui
comporteront des garanties et les
transitions et puis sur l'élection du 10
juin le chef de l'état a donc confirmé
que le 15 mai prochain dans le discours
qu'il prononcera en alsace à hoerdt près
de strasbourg
il n'a dit crapa le bon choix mais
rappellera solennellement quelle est
l'attitude de la france vis-à-vis de
l'organisation européenne sur ce débat
européen
les explications du président giscard
d'estaing
je suis convaincu depuis l'origine que
le débat à propos les élections du 10
juin prochain va se sent très
progressivement sur l'europe et je crois
qui est une bonne chose
il est toujours bon qu'un débat se
centre sur son objet principal et
j'observe communes citées à l'heure
actuelle des positions qui sont des
positions à propos de l'europe des uns
et des autres je rappellerai à propos de
l'europe qu'il y avait en france deux
grandes et vlan jadis le débat sur la
supranationalité certains hommes
certaines femmes pensaient qu'il pouvait
y avoir en europe un pouvoir
supranational comme dans un état fédéral
d'autres et est tout à fait hostile à
cette formule est c'est le grand débat
des années 50 à 60 dont peut-être
certains d'entre vous se souviennent
or j'observe que ce débat n'a plus lieu
puisque à l'heure actuelle plus personne
parmi les grandes formations politiques
de la majorité ou de l'opposition n'est
en faveur du pouvoir supranational donc
la première querelle seule organisation
de l'europe est à sauver le deuxième
débat ci était celui dont on parle est
donc vous rendiez compte dans vos
journaux dans les années 1976 1977
c'était le débat sur les pouvoirs de
l'assemblée européenne
certains craignaient que l'assemblée
européenne du fait de son élection n'en
tire parti pour étendre ses pouvoirs
j'ai rencontré comme vous le savez les
dirigeants de la majorité à cet égard
j'ai constaté qu'il n'y avait personne
nous qui à l'heure actuelle était
disposée à soutenir une extension des
pouvoirs de l'assemblée au delà des
compétences du traité de rome je dis
bien personne et comme j'ai noté que
dans l'opposition s'étaient également la
thèse du parti socialiste et que c'était
la position du parti communiste il n'y a
donc aucun mouvement politique en france
à l'heure actuelle qui propose
l'extension des pouvoirs de l'assemblée
élue au suffrage universel
si bien t2 querelles successives de
l'europe à l'heure actuelle ont été
vidés de leur contenu
il reste une question qui est de savoir
comment la france entend contribuer à
l'organisation de l'europe et à la
solution des problèmes qui se posent sur
le plan européen
comme lors des élections législatives et
lorsque l'actualité politique le
justifiera à nous allons diffuser à
partir de ce soir dans les journaux
télévisés de tf1 journal spéciale sur
les élections européennes il s'agit des
déclarations politiques des événements
des prises de positions qui vont
évidemment se multiplier au fur et à
mesure de la proche dudit jeu
michel debré à l'est républicain le
gouvernement et l'ensemble des
formations composant l'udf consacre tous
leurs efforts à critiquer le rpr simone
veil devant les cadres de l'udf
l'objectif de ma campagne mieux informer
les français sur l'europe
une confirmation au lendemain des
élections du 10 juin
simone veil se consacrera pleinement à
l'assemblée européenne michel jobert
devant le conseil du mouvement des
démocrates des élections européennes
vont se dérouler dans l'ambiguïté et
sans démocratie véritable jacques chirac
à nantes sur la contestation ou rpr
olivier guichard a pris une initiative
pour gêner mon action et nuire à notre
mouvement je ne suis pas inquiet tout
cela n'ira pas loin
et puis jacques chaban delmas à
strasbourg pour le 30e anniversaire de
la journée de l'europe sur place alain
chaillou tous les gaullistes on sait ne
se sentent pas actuellement tout à fait
à l'aise dans leur peau d'européens
certes l'immense majorité des militants
et très nombreux électeurs partage
l'analyse et les craintes de jacques
chirac
mais il ya aussi une poignée de
parlementaires qui comptait cette
attitude est la tactique du chef du rpr
témoin cette réunion provoquée il ya
deux jours par olivier guichard qui
avait réuni autour de lui 25 députés rpr
et moi aussi le discours prononcé il ya
deux heures à peine ici à strasbourg par
jacques chaban delmas
le président de l'assemblée nationale
est un européen fervent hausse et ça
depuis toujours à ses yeux d'ailleurs la
politique suivie en ce domaine par
l'actuel gouvernement et dans la
perspective de celle suivie autrefois
par le général de gaulle
pour lui c'est donc simple il faut
élargir leur accompli depuis 20 ans
aller plus loin encore traiter enfin les
vrais problèmes autrement dit organiser
enfin l'europe des réalités en fait
l'ancien premier ministre georges
pompidou qui c'est délibérément abstenu
de polémiquer ou d'inciter le rpr atouts
fractionnisme a tout de même tenu sans
le nommer il est vrai à prendre ses
distances à l'égard de jacques chirac en
prononçant ce long plaidoyer européen et
en regrettant je cite le hourvari fait
autour de ces élections le hourvari qui
n'est somme toute qu'une variante du
tohu-bohu dénoncé il ya peu par le
président giscard d'estaing les débats
de la prochaine assemblée seront
d'autant plus fructueux que les
compétences de ladite assemblée sont
connus et ses pouvoirs de décision
clairement précisée par les traités dans
le respect s'impose à tous
en ce qui concerne la france où de
nombreuses craintes ont été manifestées
de divers côtés il ressort au moins
d'humour varie politiques de ces
dernières semaines qu'un consensus
existe entre le pouvoir sa majorité et
au delà
l'opposition pour que soit appliqué
intégralement et uniquement le traité de
rome europe toujours monsieur raymond
barre le premier ministre était l'invité
du congrès de l'union travailliste dont
le président est monsieur gilbert grand
val ancien ministre du général de gaulle
l'union travailliste est devenu
aujourd'hui union gaulliste pour la
démocratie elle rassemble donc les
gaullistes qui soutiennent la politique
du président valéry giscard d'estaing
monsieur raymond barre a défini la
politique européenne du gouvernement
français nous voulons une europe
organisé nous voulons une europe qui est
une forme confédéral c'est à dire qui
respecte la personnalité des états et
qui soit fondé sur l'accord des états
nous voulons enfin une europe qui soit
mais presse de son destin
ce que le général de gaulle appelait
l'europe européenne ou choisir et en
toute liberté
d'ailleurs je me permettrai pas en ce
qui me concerne d'influer sur vos choix
ce que je voulais que vous sachiez
seulement c'était les grands axes de la
politique conduite par le gouvernement
sous l'autorité du président de la
république en matière européenne et je
ne laisserai jamais dit non mesdames
messieurs que le gouvernement que j'ai
l'honneur de diriger est un gouvernement
qui consent à l'abaissement de la france
et qui ne défend pas les intérêts de la
france il faut faire en sorte que la
france ne puisse jamais être piétine et
bien mesdames messieurs c'est notre
affaire à tous
c'est la sphère du gouvernement mais
c'est toshiba vaut le chauffeur livreur
qui avait transporté dans son camion les
armes et les échelles utilisé jeudi
dernier par quatre détenus de la prison
de fleury mérogis a été remis en liberté
aucune précision n'a été donnée sur
l'origine de cette décision du substitut
du procureur de la république à evry
premier club qualifié pour les demi
finales du championnat de france de
rugby le racing club de narbonne qui a
battu bayonne cet après-midi par 18 à 7
les autres rencontres deux quarts de
finale opposeront demain bannières et
nice le stade toulousain et clermont
ferrand et enfin agen aigrelet graulhet
un club que pierre thorette allez
découvrir au coeur d'une bien jolie
ville le drapeau rouge et noir flotte
sur la marmite du championnat de rugby
avec le stade toulousain le sporting de
graulhet est en effet le deuxième des
huit clubs rester en lice pour les
quarts de finale à porter ses couleurs
cependant on aurait tort d'y voir en la
circonstance les symboles habituel de la
révolte et de l'anarchie
car pour ce qui concerne grouiller on ne
saurait parler mieux que de calme de
sérénité pour évoquer le charme discret
de cette très vieille cité du tarn
- installer sans doute dans l'histoire
est la renommée qu'albi sa voisine mais
paraît aux yeux de ceux qui la
connaissent de l'oréal que lui confère
un sens merveilleux de l'accueil et de
l'amitié témoigner par ses habitants
whittier alors de ces magicie qui en ont
fait depuis un siècle un des centres
mondiaux du traitement déposer des cuirs
grouiller depuis 25 ans joint le talent
de ces rugbymen avec narbonne et agen
goyer figure parmi les trois seuls clubs
qui allie également en quarts de finale
de nationale b leur équipe réserve
par trois fois déjà demi-finaliste en
1957 66 et 67
le sporting ne semble disposer des
meilleurs atouts pour atteindre cette
fois le stade ultime de l'épreuve
la force de cette équipe sans vedettes
mais aussi sans faiblesse réside en
effet dans son équilibre et son
homogénéité avec à chaque niveau un
joueur qui conduit tout inspire
l'ensemble gasc en troisième ligne la
porte à l'ouverture rouzière à l'arrière
ironie du sort mais aussi preuve de sa
vitalité
la malchance a touché deux fois à
travers ces éléments moteurs sans
paraître l'amoindrir gasc d'abord
suspendu pour un geste malheureux en
huitième devant grenoble et qui a suivi
tristement le dernier entraînement
la porte ensuite victime d'un début
d'angine est réduit pour sa part à rêver
devant les trophées du club avec
l'espoir de vérifier demain qu'il s'agit
bien là du mal des hommes en forme et
puis à travers cet ensemble apparaît
comme du fond d'un révélateur la figure
d'un homme qui fut un joueur modeste
mais qui s'affirme excellent entraîneur
henri auriol et moi j'espère images
qu'on va faire un grand match d'abord
agi comme moi jouer c'est ce que je
préconisais continuellement alors on ne
se trouve une équipe d'agen qui elle
aussi est une équipe qui joue le ballon
et je pense qu'il n'y a pas de problème
de ce côté là il y aura du jeu eu un jeu
beaucoup plus élargie peut être que le
nôtre où un jeu un peu plus de
percussion mais je crois qu'on va voir
du jeu tout broyer bien sûr en accepte
l'auguré pour que le drapeau rouge et
noir puisse enfin se déployer
entièrement sur le champ du rugby
français le tour d'espagne cycliste la
vuelta a donné des émotions
organisateurs en effet il ya une chute
près l'arrivée de la 11e étape à la
suite d'un accident et d'une bagarre
avec le service d'ordre
le coureur italien tine sheila
souffrirait d'une fracture du poignet du
poignet droit michel pollentier souffre
de contusions multiples de wolf a reçu
des coups sur tout le corps et
l'irlandais kelly est passé à travers la
lunette arrière d'une voiture
c'est finalement noël deux jokers qui a
gagné cette arrivée qui a gagné cette
étape 11e étape de la vuelta au
classement général après l'arrivée
de cette 11e étape saragosse pampelune
c'est le français levasseur qui est en
tête devant le hollandais hotmail et
l'espagnol yanez la région parisienne a
battu aujourd'hui un record absolu de
froid à paris 1,5 mais depuis
l'ouverture de l'observatoire en 1873 il
a fait 9 degrés 9 c la température la
plus basse
le précédent record datait de 1910 le 5
mai 1910 il avait fait 10 degrés record
battu cet après midi il y avait 5 degrés
à strasbourg 6 degrés à lille et
clermont ferrand trait à toulouse 16 à
perpignan 17 ajaccio demain offensive
générale du beau temps les températures
seront en nette hausse demain après midi
seulement car dans la matinée eh bien il
fera encore assez froid vers 23h30
jacques le noir vous présentera le
dernier journal bonsoir